you
[Music]
coming up next on book tv afterwards our
hour-long series where we invite guest
hosts to interview authors
this week financial writer and
washington post columnist sebastian
maliby goes inside the world of hedge
funds in his new book more money than
god the former reporter and bureau chief
for the economist magazine says that the
hedge fund industry has survived the
current recession better than most
divisions of the financial sector he
discusses the reasons for that success
with jillian ted u.s managing editor of
the financial times
[Music]
hello sebastian and thank you for
joining me to talk about your new book
more money than god
which i must say i found a fascinating
read and i really want to congratulate
you
because not only have you got great
characters great personalities really
fantastically memorable stories you're
also touching on some very big important
economic themes about where we go in the
future with financial regulation
and something i find fascinating is that
most ordinary people if they pick up a
book about hedge funds called more money
than god hedge funding than god hedge
funds and the making of a new elite
they'd assume that you've written a book
that's basically bashing hedge funds
because that's been the popular line in
recent years and yet but if you look at
across the financial system and you say
well there's going to be financial risk
festival let's just stipulate currencies
will go up and down
interest rates will go up and down
there'll be difficult decisions about
where you allocate scarce capital in an
incredibly complex economy and you'll
make mistakes there will be
bubbles and crashes and so forth which
is the least bad kind of financial
vehicle in which to entrust investment
capital
and i think what history shows is that
hedge funds are rather good at this i
mean during the crisis in 2007 2008 they
came out well 2007 when everybody else
was losing money uh from subprime
mortgage investments the hedge funds
were on average up ten percent uh even
the hedge funds that were supposed to
specialize in asset-backed securities in
other words that includes subprime
mortgages they were flat for the year so
they totally dodged the bullet at a time
when you know everybody else was
some of them still went bust though i
mean i remember writing stories of
myself as a journalist about funds that
were going bust so would capital went
best in 2007 that's one example but
there were there were several as you say
and in fact one of the nice things about
hedge funds one of the attractions is
they do fail but they are small enough
to fail they're not too big to fail when
they fail they go down and in fact about
5000 did go burst in the last decade but
they do so without
taxpayers taking a hit without the
government getting involved and also
even without creditors in general taking
a hit because what happens is
hedge funds mark all their positions to
market so when they start losing money
you see it instantly and because of the
way they borrow money on short-term
basis
from borrowers who can sort of basically
yank the loans in immediately when they
go down by about 50 or so they tend to
be wound up
before the lenders the creditors have to
lose any money so you're basically
saying it's a good thing if the hedge
funds do the risky stuff because they
can kind of die and we don't really care
exactly
what about long-term capital management
because they have an example of a hedge
fund that did implode spectacularly and
it created a huge almost systemic crisis
well i think the almost is quite
interesting there i mean i agree with
that it is almost but not quite i mean
in the long term capital management case
what happened was that the fed came in
and convened the meeting at which the
bankers you know were made to
were armed twisted
into providing a recapitalization there
was no government money involved and in
fact peter fisher the fed official
who convened those meetings
explained to me how you know he was
getting ready to stand on the table if
the bankers hadn't provided the cash
to tell everyone to put down their cell
phones and there was going to be a
public announcement at the same time so
nobody could call their own bank to say
that the bailout had failed
what that story tells you is that there
was no plan b for the fed it wasn't as
though if the private sector had failed
to do a bail-in uh the government would
have come in with money uh in the end
and so uh you know long-term capital is
a warning sign
but it did actually shape the system as
a whole because it's all very well
saying well these hedge funds are so
small we don't really care about them if
you look at how big some of these funds
have become they're bigger sometimes
with their assets under management than
your average small bank in some
countries i mean
yeah i mean if you if you think about uh
bear stones right
which was um when it went down in 2007
uh considered to be on the cusp of
whether it really needed to be installed
a debate about that whether you had to
bail out uh bear stones and i think best
dance assets before it went wrong
were in the order of 300 billion
something like that
if you look for hedge funds which have
assets of 300 billion in other words
capital times leverage
they're incredibly scarce i mean you
know i would think that if you take the
9 000 and something hedge funds that
there are you might find a dozen maybe
two dozen that
hit that criterion
so
of course there are exceptions the
really big ones as you quite rightly say
do warrant public attention but they are
such a small fraction of the total
uh that i think the bigger point that
people need to understand is that most
of these things should just be
encouraged the government should
encourage hedge funds because they're
more fortunate what they're doing at the
moment i mean if you look to europe the
eurozone i mean people talk about hedge
funds being like locusts and there
really is a sense that hedge funds are
the ones who are destabilizing the
system and even in america with the
financial reform bill there is now a
requirement that hedge funds are
registered and essentially subject to
more scrutiny i mean do you think that's
the right thing to do or do you think
that's missing the boat crazy crazy i
mean
the rule in america is going to be if
you have a hundred million dollars in
equity you have to register with the
securities and exchange commission when
i'm sorry 100 million dollars is de
minimis it's nothing it could just you
know you can not to ordinary people it
doesn't they no no but in terms of the
financial system if the public uh
concern here is that a hedge fund could
destabilize finance at that kind of size
you simply can't
so why is the sec going to waste its
time
taking all these registrations what will
it do with that information
why create a barrier to entry when i was
researching my book i met
a woman who had recently graduated from
yale law school
and so she knew the law and for some
reason she knew china very well so she
set up a hedge fund that would invest in
chinese bankruptcies because she could
figure out in a bankruptcy which piece
of debt in in china would pay out at
what
kind of smart entrepreneurial american
dream if you like yeah exactly and it
it's you know she went to her friends um
who had also been at yale law school
with her and they weren't rich because
they still had some student debt they
were working for public prosecutors
whatever but they had a few thousand
dollars that they could have invested
but that is illegal in the united states
because you cannot raise money as a
hedge fund from investors who have less
than i think five million dollars in
liquid investable assets
and so this is an example where you know
well-intentioned regulation which says
let's not have regular people invest in
hedge funds and that might be the right
call but we have to remember that the
consequences it creates a barrier to
entry for these small attractive
entrepreneurial boutiques which ought to
be managing the risk right i mean the
iron is of course that in recent years
many of the banks themselves have
started to act a bit like hedge funds i
mean do you think that all the risky
activity or the hedge fund trading
should be taken out of the banks is that
what you'd refer and yeah basically lots
of the colorful characters you write
about would be the only ones doing it
and the banks would be boring like
utilities
i do think that there is a problem when
you put very risky activities and
basically government insured government
backstop institutions which are backstop
both in the sense that they take
deposits which are federally insured you
know if they have an asset liability
mismatch they borrow too much short term
they have insurance in the form of
access to the federal reserve's lending
you know those kinds of safeguard and
just the fact that they might be too big
to fail and therefore you know that's
another third kind of backstop
that just encourages you to take too
much risk
and it encourages your lenders to think
they can lend without really
scrutinizing
how risky you are as you've written a
lot in the financial times
so i think that separating out this
risky activity and putting it in a
vehicle where the investors the hedge
fund managers have skin in the game if
they lose it's their own money because
they invest their own savings it's not
too big to fail it's small enough to
fail there's no federal deposit
insurance whatever
i think that's much more healthy so the
volcker rule
which is trying to separate out the two
activities is good in principle the
question is in practice drawing those
lines well that's going to be an issue
people are going to be fighting back for
a long time because of course there's a
lot to be done in terms of actually
turning the financial bill into tangible
rules
but
i mean i think a lot of people who pick
up your book with this fantastic title
and where did you get that idea from by
the way i mean was that your um was that
your agents your your publishers did you
like the title it came out of a
discussion with my brilliant agent um
but it was
really he must have really irritated a
lot of hedgehog managers it doesn't go
down too well i'm afraid with the hedge
fund managers but hey
the truth is that i mean i think it's a
fair title in the sense that when jp
morgan died
in 1913 there were two facts about it
one was that he was known as jupiter
because of his god-like pirate wall
street the second was that his entire
fortune in today's dollars came to one
point four billion dollars that's what
it's only 1.4 billion that's a lot of
money for ordinary people but i mean
compared to some of the guys you write
about in your book i mean that's almost
peanuts there are plenty of guys in my
book who make 1.4 billion dollars in one
year right they make more money than
jupiter or more money than god in one
year so i think the title is
perfectly fair but isn't that part of
the problem because i would bet that the
real reason a lot of people pick up this
book and want to read it it's actually
not about the serious policy stuff not
the kind of geeky question about how you
put risk in the system they want to read
it because it's a fantastic inside story
of some of these characters and these
really are amazing characters i mean
starting even with the original founder
of the hedge fund idea can you tell me a
bit about you know how and why this
hedge fund concept first sprung up well
alfred winslow jones set up the first
hedged fund as he called it in 1949 and
he was an interesting character he'd
been sent to berlin
as a young state department official in
1930 when the nazis were just starting
to rise he'd fallen in love with a
beautiful german anti-nazi activist
and he'd uh you know he became a passion
not only about her but about her cause
right so he started running these
undercover anti-nazi missions going to
britain going to other places to try to
raise money for the underground
essentially
and even after his wife
divorced him she was by the way a serial
uh marriager of various people for
various reasons
often happens even today on wall street
but yeah
uh he you know he came back settled down
in new york married an american woman
the second time and said honey um now
that we're married we should have a
honeymoon i think we should go to the
front lines of the civil war in spain
so they went and they were a risk taker
in every sense exactly you know they met
ernest hemingway they went to the front
lines with dorothy parker and that was
the kind of person he was when he set up
his hedge fund um it was he didn't
become a journalist but he wanted to
make some more money so this is sort of
plan b to
to try to do it through investments um
he set up this fund and he did the same
thing as before he was secret
clandestine under the radar so he didn't
register with any regulator he didn't
advertise to anybody he just raised
money by word of mouth which you know
often meant a word between my force at
his dinner table
so that's how it all got started
wow so the same kind of subversive
clandestine approach
fed into the hedge fund world at the
beginning coupled with some intellectual
insights of course and i mean how would
you actually define the hedge fund i
mean perhaps we should have started that
at the beginning because you know the
word hedge funds chucked around very
loosely but what for you are the key
elements that
have been there all the way through well
i think apart from this element of
trying to avoid regulation and therefore
maintaining flexibility of investment
style
the other things are
the incentive fee uh a.w jones the
founder said you know the phoenician
merchants of ancient time when they took
a successful sea voyage
they would share the profits with their
financial backers the the backers got 20
percent uh
i'm sorry the backers got the 80 percent
and the and the captain the c captain
took a fifth jones said i'm the c
captain i'm taking a fifth of the upside
here and that incentive fee you know has
has made it you know basically spurred
hedge fund managers to really push for
the inside the edge that will make them
beat the opposition
so that's the second characteristic um
and that's where the 2022
ideas come from right from the beginning
because even today most hedge funds at
least until very recently were typically
paying their managers 20 of the upside
20 of the profit that's right and i
think that does you know give you the
incentive to to to
get the profits at the same time you put
your own money in the fund alongside
your investors so that gives you an
incentive not to be crazy so if it
worked for the phoenician sea captains
it could work for the people in
connecticut today well the phoenician
sea captain he really had skin in the
game because if he sank then that was
his skin
it's not quite like that in greenwich
connecticut today but anyway although
fun might feel like it and then there's
this hedging of course that's another
characteristic which means you know
you're long and you're short
and the point of that is that by betting
on something's going up something's
going down you're screening out the
general risk in the market so you don't
have to have a view on whether the stock
market as a whole is going up or down
you don't care what you have a view on
is that this particular company ford
motor is going to do better than the
other one you know general motors
because you think the management's
better or whatever
so you can isolate specific types of
risk that you do have a view on bet on
those and you can bet bigger by
leveraging by borrowing money because
you've hedged out the kinds of risks
that you don't have a view on
so it's being more kind of target
targeted more of a rifle shot so in a
center is the original capitalist
entrepreneurial american dream in one of
its purest forms if you like i think
that's right and so i think the final
characteristic to point to about what
defines a hedge fund is this sort of
freestanding
um boutique you know hedge fund i mean i
was struck at the beginning of my
research that if four entrepreneurial
people set up you know a kind of
quantitative fund on the west coast a
quantitative company you know it's doing
software these are software people
people love that it's on the cover of
various magazines and so forth people
think but if the same kind of people do
it on the east coast it's probably
finance it's probably a hedge fund and
people don't like that so it was a sort
of cultural double standard i wanted to
but one of the problems is that you know
if you look at somebody like bill gates
no one begrudges him his quizillions of
dollars because actually he's made
something that has enriched ordinary
people's lives
and there is a sense of doing tangible
stuff that we can actually touch and
feel and celebrate the problem about
hedge funds so to most ordinary people
is they are being earned with zillions
of dollars more money than god um they
live in a world where 1.4 billion seems
like quite a poultry sum sometimes um
and yet they're not doing stuff that
actually enriches the lives of ordinary
americans well let's take an example so
i mean somebody who really does make
more money than god is james simons who
set up a very mathematically intensive
uh quantitative fund called medallion
which has been up you know every year
since 1990 often up 50 80 in one year
so he is making uh more than a billion
every year all right
and what he does is he he he basically
uses high-order mathematics which began
with
code breaking
mathematics and then also use software
translation mathematics
to recognize short-term patterns in
markets so he might buy hold it for a
short time maybe a day or two
sell again
and so this is not only incredibly
profitable but also it's exactly what
you're talking about what does that do
for capitalism i mean you know why
should anyone care itself
rapid trading sounds like kind of candy
floss finance sort of cyber finance is
all kind of star trek finance you know
well i suppose but the answer is about
why it matters is that
if you want people to buy stocks which
we do because we want risk capital uh
people to provide money to risky
enterprises because risk-taking is what
drives new jobs new companies and so
forth
if you want them to buy stocks which
have risk you need to be
they need to be able to sell those
stocks as well
and when you have lots of participants
like james simons coming in coming out
they're effectively making it so liquid
there's so much trading in the markets
that people's exit from a position they
suddenly don't like
is much cheaper they know that there
will be somebody they can sell to
because there's so much activity all the
time
and so although it's very abstract and
it's understandable that people don't
see why it's beneficial the truth is
that actually rapid trading hedge funds
are making it possible for ordinary
investors to allocate capital to risky
companies and drive the drive the
economy forward but isn't the problem
though that you know okay you had those
incredibly smart eggheads who if they
weren't off doing hedge funds would
probably be off of creating something in
silicon valley um
first of all maybe they would be better
for the economy if they were doing
things in silicon valley and actually
doing tangible engineering stuff science
stuff you know the type of activities
that america so badly needs to be
developed but secondly isn't there the
danger that they're so much smarter than
everyone else they're constantly going
to be preying on the dumb money i mean
you and i um probably have a lot of our
money tied up in pensions and dumb money
kind of products and they will always
end up being the losers to the hedge
funds well it's two really good points
right so but the first one is you know
uh could we better allocate this human
capital and it's true you're going to
see james simon says uh campus on long
island you know and they're all these
incredible not just phds but people who
are established
you know mid-career academics and then
they become the best statistician
in academic mathematics and then they
get hired by renaissance technologies
and they no longer publish because
everything they do is secret now and
it's about perfecting their black box
trading system which means basically all
the ordinary researchers who could
actually benefit from that research lose
out yeah and then when i was going down
the corridors of this uh this campus
first of all you see these little
mirrors on the corners which are those
kind where you if you're coming around
the corner you can see what's coming and
that was installed because one of these
mathematicians goes around on a unicycle
and you need to be able to see if he's
coming in case he might crash into you
in his previous life this guy this guy
was inventing at ibm research lab he was
inventing new translation software
and now he's not doing that he's doing
finance
then this other guy this mathematician
you know on his door i think it was
saying one of these people had a sort of
a little journal article sort of stuck
up and it said
why most published research is false in
other words now i'm not publishing i'm
just doing this research i'm putting it
into the hedge funds black box yeah but
i'm not sharing it with the general
public now is that a misallocation of
human capital well
i think the answer is first of all
we don't have a magic wand
nobody knows precisely how we should
allocate the smartest people around the
economy so either we've got to let the
market do it
you know or we're going to override the
market with some presumably government
policy that says we're going to drive
people out of finance into something
else how does the government know i mean
wouldn't the government make more of a
mess in allocating human capital in the
market the market isn't perfect but
would the government be better that's
one kind of point so if it was really
truly economically valuable for the
economy as a whole
to be having more bright people going
into saying making widgets in ohio then
the market system should have evolved
that way to reward that is that what
you're kind of trying to say well i
think i'm making first of all a less
ambitious claim which is simply that
even if the market's a bit wrong
it might be less wrong than the
government would be if the government
came and said we brilliantly know better
that we should have allocated some of
these mathematicians uh to software
development what happens if actually
software development in the next 20
years turns out to be a stagnant place
and you should have put them instead in
human sciences or biotech yes yeah
biotech exactly so it's very difficult
to allocate smart people and nobody
knows how to do it and maybe the market
is less bad okay so that's the
justification for why they're all
sitting there all those brains sitting
there in connecticut or greenwich or
whatever what about the problem that
actually they're so much smarter than
your mum-and-pop investor that the
average person will always get screwed
or always get into trouble if they are
basically um trading against a hedge
fund well one of the things that people
don't always remember is that although
it's true that around 1990
nearly all the money in hedge funds was
from rich individuals
by now about two thirds of the money in
hedge funds comes from institutions
and that's a transformation and so it
means that you know university college
endowments have their money in hedge
funds uh retirement systems put their
money in hedge funds non-profits like
the one i work for the council on
foreign relations they invest the
endowment that's funding the research in
hedge funds so when hedge funds do well
it's actually benefiting not just rich
people it's benefiting some social
causes so if you go to yale university
uh you know they did a study actually in
2005 and they said our endowment now has
14 billion dollars in it at that time
how much of this is due to the way that
we've been investing in hedge funds
since 1990 and they figured out that
basically they'd outperformed the
average
college endowment and the out
performance had generated 7.8 billion
out of the 14 billion that they had
so
more than half of their money was the
result of uh
better investment management so that the
guy who'd done this david swenson the
manager of the yale endowment you know
had basically given more to you know
merit scholarships science facilities
than any of the storied education
philanthropists one could think of you
know harkness melon forget it i mean one
guy david swenson who was putting money
in hedge funds had done more for yale
so of course in 2008 that all went
horribly wrong and yeah
that's true in 2009 they came back so i
think you know
okay so that's the social justification
that actually you know hedge funds don't
just uphold the capitalist mark free
market principles but they also
essentially create wealth that can
benefit people beyond just the hedge
fund managers but the problem is though
that to go back to your venetian sea
captain you still have 20 percent of the
upside or 20 of the profit going to a
very small group of people
and one of the things that makes your
book compelling reading is the details
of what these guys do with this money i
mean that is just fascinating i mean do
you want to tell me a bit about some of
your favorite anecdotes of some of the
um wonderful examples of conspicuous
bending or extraordinary lifestyles that
most people don't usually
um get to see well i think there was a
guy called lewis bacon you know who runs
more capital and
he was the one who put the sea turtle
monitors on or something yeah he wanted
to he's a great conservationist and he
wanted to monitor exactly the um habits
of these
turtles so he he put little electronic
monitors on them to see where they were
going
um you know you have um steve cohen of
sac capital who apparently has um at his
home not only you know his own golf
course and all that kind of thing but
also he somehow had a planetarium with
the ceiling which was painted with a
precise constellation of stars
that had been there on his wedding night
of sort of 15 years earlier well that's
quite sweet
i mean it's also an extraordinary use of
money but
it's also quite sweet
and then of course there's some
philanthropy which we shouldn't forget i
mean there's jewish soros and in the
current environment i guess the question
still is you know if you believe in the
american dream if you believe in
rewarding people who are taking risks do
you actually need to reward them that
much no i don't think you do i mean i do
think that one of the things that alfred
jones
kind of came up with at the beginning
has turned out to be a bit pernicious
which is that he counted the investment
profits that he took that 20 percent he
counted as a capital gain
so it was taxed at the low capital gains
rate not the higher income tax rate and
that continues to be an argument to this
day should we change that uh to make it
taxable at the income tax rate so
they're basically tax dodging in a sense
or not tax dodging but they're basically
once again gaming the system in a very
clever way because you have these clever
brains yes for the benefit yes that
that's totally right and you're probably
trying in some cases probably paying
less tax on your average cleaner i would
imagine yeah indeed the cleaners who
come in clean they're in kitchens are
paying a higher tax rate or probably
well it depends on what income tax
bracket there and maybe not um but
certainly it doesn't pass the smell test
to have people who for a living invest
and then they get paid income for that
investing and they say it's a capital
gain i'm sorry i don't think it's a
capital gain i mean when you have not
only a fiscal crisis which we're all
going to live with for the next decade
plus right
which has been massively exacerbated by
the financial crisis and we need revenue
from somewhere but also you've got all
these data that show that the hugest
inequality that has emerged in the area
of globalization is not really between
sort of the averagely rich and the rest
is between the super-rich which have
just exponentially taken off
and i think raising taxes on those
people is fair and necessary and in the
case of hedge funds i think it's just
obvious that we should tax their income
as income i can't warn you many friends
amongst hedge fund community for saying
that no it doesn't what the title along
with the title yeah i've got the title
against me i've got the tax position
against me but but i mean there again i
must say you know presumably if you have
1.4 billion or 14 billion dollars i mean
yeah the average person would say well
why complain about losing an extra two
or three billion dollars yeah and
actually you know are you really gonna
miss it yeah sometimes if you if you put
them in a quiet room uh i think hedge
fund managers themselves would admit
that it's perfectly fair to attack i
mean i certainly know some who believe
this that they should pay more tax and
they should pay this carried interest
should be taxed income
and they don't have an objection to that
and really at a certain point money
is more than you can spend yeah
and it's about keeping score so you want
to show that you're clever because
you've earned this much but if you have
to pay more tax it's not as if you're
going to move to some tax haven like
bermuda where you can't see your friends
anymore you're going to stay in new york
and greenwich
i mean mostly it strikes me from a
political sense given that we are living
at a time of tremendous public anger
tremendous public pain i mean average
people are really suffering
not just in america but europe too and
there is invariably growing envy and
frustration and finger-pointing
um don't you think it would be very
smart thing for the hedge fund industry
to do to actually come out and
voluntarily say that there should
actually be some change in tax code to
show that it was playing its part yeah i
think it would be good um you know one
is asking them to sacrifice the piece of
their operation which means the most to
them how much they take home
so maybe it's not going to happen
but i think even if they don't come out
and say that it should be done to them i
mean i think and do you think the
government would ever have the
balls to do that i mean in london we've
started some kind of debate about that
um the european commission again as
talking about trying to look at this but
i mean there hasn't really been very
much actually done yet um do you think
the obama administration would ever have
the courage to talk about
re-examining the tax code
or tax treatment you know i mean when
you talk about re-examining the tax code
of course there are all kinds of things
that should be fixed i mean my other
hobby horses you know the extraordinary
tax break that goes to property to all
kinds of real estate investment
which actually doesn't really boost home
ownership if you look at the
cross-country numbers uh and simply
encourages households to take enormous
mortgages in other words to have
leverage haven't we discovered that
leverage is bad i mean there's too much
of it and yet we're subsidizing leverage
at the same level so politicians are
kind of hooked on it yeah
but of course as you know in the uk
in the 1980s following a housing crash
the smaller mortgage deduction that
existed then was abolished so
governments democratically elected
governments can sometimes do something
about ridiculous tax breaks
and so maybe in an environment where we
need tax revenue that could be
re-examined and i think on hedge funds
sooner or later i hope that you know the
right thing will happen they will pay
income tax the trouble comes every time
is that when you propose this
then you know you're basically going to
propose a change for all partnerships
not just hedge fund partnerships and
there'll be some other kind of
partnership you know restaurants or
something which will say you know the
chef has been toiling away in that hot
hot kitchen you know he's created his
restaurant you know that's a capital
gain you just look about all the fights
over financial regulation and how laws
of unintended consequences came to play
and all the lobbying started and you can
certainly imagine
imagine that but
i'm curious you know you say when you
sit down and talk quietly to the hedge
fund figures they some of them might say
well actually perhaps some change in the
tax
treatment might be fair or not but how
do you even get to sit down quietly with
the hedge fund figures because
one of the things that makes this whole
sector fascinating is the fact they have
been very secretive ever since the early
days when they were taking clandestine
anti-nazi um
approaches to actually fuel what they
were doing you know they aren't an easy
world to actually penetrate how did you
get in there and actually get them to
talk to you well i mean for one thing it
took a long time it took me maybe three
three and a half years to do this book
uh you know what made you decide to
write it actually partly this i mean in
a sense you know the the challenge of
looking at you look at the global
economy look at the financial sector
much of it is pretty transparent
everyone's happy to talk about
themselves the information is there on
the internet the exception
seemed to be the secretive mysterious
frontier of
of hedge funds and so as an
investigative journalist
that was an attraction to try and break
into that
make them list the kimono
and you know it wasn't quick
but my idea was first of all that if i
went to the founding fathers of this
industry they don't have proprietary
secrets anymore and they've stopped
trading so
whatever secret source they used to have
isn't terribly valuable anymore so plus
they retire so they have time so you go
and see these people first you really
spend a lot of time with them you really
understand what they did you really make
them understand that you understand and
then you say and presumably you were
doing that before the financial crisis
started oh yeah yeah yeah no i had this
idea for this book in 2006. right you
know so we're really at the point of the
credit boom in many ways right right so
they would have been feeling pretty good
about life as well i imagine you know
1.4 billion probably would have been 2.4
billion or something even bigger yes and
also it's human nature you know
supposing you've got a hedge fund
manager like michael steinhardt you know
who's an explosive character who managed
his hedge fund from the late 60s to the
mid-1990s
uh he was the one who famously told
somebody when someone said they wanted
to kill themselves he said right can i
watch is that the one exactly exactly
and he you know when trading got tense
he would light up two cigarettes at once
and he would yell at people all the time
and i mean they are extraordinary
characters
yeah um so so you go and see someone
like that um and you know he hasn't been
trading since 1995 actively but he did
have this storied career um before and
so he would quite like some recognition
so i mean he's happy to talk
and in fact i saw him multiple times he
was very nice to me even though he kept
used to yell at his own trading staff i
was in his office one day when he
discovered that he'd lost money in the
bernie madoff scandal
and you thought he would have been in a
bad mood
but in fact he was perfectly nice to me
and he kind of muttered you know
furiously about how he lost this money
but carried on talking to me clearly
sharp enough to tell what you were up to
and so was trying to
play the system well as well
i imagine
but he really told stories about how in
effect in the 70s he broke the rules
um and you know some of the money that
he made
was by being in this very secretive kind
of close-knit club of block traders who
used to trade enormous blocks of stock
together
and he had basically better information
than everybody else
and it wasn't always exactly on the up
and up
but it was highly profitable and he said
that to me on tape
so people are quite relaxed if you're
talking about what they did a long time
ago yes and then the key thing as you go
forward in the research is
that you you've now
talked to and sort of won the trust of
the mentors of the next generation
so if you go and see george soros you
spend a lot of time with him you really
understand what he did then he will
introduce you to people who used to work
for him and then bit by bit those people
introduce you to the next people until
right at the end of my research i was
getting a call i was in my office one
day you know writing chapter 16 or
something and the phone went and and
there was a bruce covener uh one of the
more secretive people absolutely i mean
most people watching this probably never
even heard of his name but he's a
tremendously powerful player isn't he
exactly i mean he tell me what he does a
bit i mean well he set up a fund called
caxton um which is a macro trading fund
in other words it plays on currencies um
interest rates and sort of plays off a
macroeconomic view of where growth is
going to go up and down
he started in the late 70s he was he was
somebody who began with political
science uh then he got frustrated with
that tried to be a musician
didn't quite go professional with that
was driving a cab in new york borrowed
some money on a credit card
and bettered on commodities and sort of
tripled his money or something so the
original american dream uh yeah and he
he realized he had a knack for this and
he joined a company called commodities
corporation in the 1970s which was based
in princeton it's one of the very early
um sort of trend following commodity
trading secretive outfits not in new
york but in this farmhouse
outside princeton uh interestingly she
was set up with the help of
paul samuelson the nobel laureate who
had written
in his economics writing about how
markets are
are efficient but in his personal
investing was betting on these traders
on the idea that you could beat markets
um
because that's a very interesting theme
of your book about the efficient market
hypothesis yeah so anyway bruce covenant
began there he then set up his own
company cast and he grew it and became
bigger and bigger and bigger and was
extremely successful quite influential
in conservative political circles was
the chairman of the american enterprise
institute a bit of a neo-conservative
godfather uh very secretive to the press
but you know there he was suddenly
telephoning me uh because he talked to
you today yeah um you know but
apparently he did it because by that
time i'd already had a four-hour dinner
with somebody who had worked with him
for 15 years so he knew that i knew
about what he'd done so he might as well
talk at that point so it really was a
labor of love then i mean
did you find though that their ability
or their willingness to talk to you
and their willingness to be frank
changed as a result of the crisis
because i mean as a journalist for
example i spent a number of years
looking i'd say in the
shadowy worlds of the complex credit
markets and certainly before 2007 and
after say particularly 2008 there was a
change because people became much more
frightened and much less willing to chat
openly yeah i think there were two
things i mean first of all
they were frightened and secondly they
were stressed and busy i mean 2008 if
you were managing money was one of the
most hectic intense years ever
and so i was trying to get
interviews during that period it wasn't
always easy i remember being on the
train from washington to new york uh
having finally snagged my first
interview with paul tudor jones who is
another sort of you know legendary
figure in this industry and again
someone who doesn't talk that much
usually hardly ever
so i was very excited i think i was
getting the first interview that you
know he'd given in in more than a decade
or something
and you know my cell phone went on the
train and he was canceling the interview
and i was told you know you'll
understand why tomorrow and sure enough
the next day there was something in the
papers about how his long-time equity
trading partner james belotta you know
they'd split and basically plot had been
forced out and there were all these
changes going on in 2008 which just you
know made talking to a writer
not the highest thing on people's
priority lists so i was battling against
that
out of all the characters you tracked
and you really do i mean how many hedge
fund managers have you talked to to do
this book no i lost count i mean i think
i did um
you know
hundreds of hours of taped interviews
transcripts and so forth i mean i i
forget how many precisely but
who did you end up admiring most
gosh um
some of the people are most fascinating
are the ones who who don't necessarily
explain what they're up to
very accurately i mean paultea de jones
is a fascinating example
where he thinks he makes money because
he looks for market analogues
he looks for times you know he says okay
today i'm looking at the market uh the s
p 500 index is going up the volume of
trading is going down the gold price is
doing that the oil price isn't doing
this the dollar is doing the other and
he says to his research team find me the
past times in markets where these five
conditions held and they scurry away and
they come back an hour later with charts
of all these and he looks at this stuff
he said okay now i can see how it worked
out in history when these conditions
held
and so i'm going to trade this now i
know for a fact because i've talked to
people at his company who sort of
analyzed the track record
that this is nonsense he didn't make
money by this in fact there's no profit
to be had out of these analogs he
doesn't believe this but i'm sure it's
not not the case that he makes money
like that and it reminds me of vic
braden the famous tennis coach who said
that if you ask tennis praise you know
why is mcenroe's forehand so fantastic
you know is it how he stands is it his
shoulders is it that he he flicks his
risk early for that you know top spin or
what is it you know not only do the
tennis pros not know the answer mcenroe
himself might tell you the wrong answer
and you can film him
and break the the forehand you know film
down into slow motion so you really see
how he does it and it's not what he told
you he did
and it's a bit like that with some hedge
fund traders and so i don't know if
that's whether you know admiring them
for that is the right almost like an
artistic or creative genius for smelling
trades or smelling ability to make money
yeah and so sort of the intellectual
fascination is see no they provided an
explanation which isn't right
but in the seeds or in the margins of
that explanation there's something else
which does make intellectual sense about
why they made money and so with paul
jones for example i ended up thinking
that
it's a bit like going for a walk going
for a walk doesn't cause you to have
inspiration for what you should write in
your next column in the financial times
um
it doesn't it's not that the walk
creates the column but it puts you in
the frame of mind
where an idea might come to you and i
think with paul jones when he looks at
these analogues these charts it puts
them in the frame of mind where an idea
comes to him right right
i mean if you were a young hedge fund
wannabe coming out of college saying and
i look at all this money i too would
like to have more money than god i mean
who would you recommend they
they look at as a good example i think
somebody like that would have to play to
his or her strengths i mean you would
need to decide are you a
mathematical quantitative type in which
case you know your dream is to join
renaissance technologies but for this
you need you know higher order
quantitative phd plus you need to be a
super geek basically yeah exactly or are
you somebody who likes to go and kick
the tires at real main street companies
in which case you should work for a
stock picking
hedge fund that goes out and really
understands how a company works and
decides is it going up is it going down
shall i be long shall i be short and
there are hedge funds like that that
really do make
persistent consistent money
that was one of the things that
surprised me you know because academics
always take mutual fund you know stock
pickers as the one of the proofs that
markets are efficient the prices are
random because there's no persistence in
performance
amongst mutual fund investors the funny
thing is that hedge funds that do pretty
much the same thing
do have
persistence in performance and do make
money
so
you know i think you can play to your
strengths there are other kinds of
people who just have a
gut for risk
i mean george soros his great talent in
a way was when he saw a good trade
he would pile on with everything he had
he said there's no such thing as being
too much of a pig if you see the chance
just just go for it yes
so i think there are different
styles and who did you end up from from
your research
not admiring
hmm
who did you least like out of all the
vast stable characters you looked at
um
i suppose you know
i mean it's harsh to say this since we
got along quite well but you know
michael steinhardt
is somebody who in the end i think made
money
um
by just basically being inside a club
you know that he got the first call
uh i mean the way it worked was that
there were three big brokerages in the
70s and the 80s that were moving very
big blocks of stock and they needed
somebody to sell that block to a pension
fund was selling they needed to buy it
and so they just knew that michael
steinhardt was the guy to call because
he didn't mind in the space of one phone
call saying yes
to a sort of multi-million dollar
purchase the thing was you know let's
imagine i'm the broker you're michael
steiner i call you up and say will you
take this
now if you say
no
i'm totally stuck because now i've given
you the information that there's this
big cell coming
so you're gonna you could say no and
then go out and just sell ahead of me
so basically you can say i'm not sure uh
but i'll take it if you give me a three
dollar discount per share and you've
basically got them by the shortened
codes right that doesn't strike me as
the most
intellectually innovative way to make a
fortune so it was basically about
negotiating the power balance between
yourself and the bankers being in the
right time place at the right time i
mean one of the fascinating things that
you capture in your book is the way that
hedge funds have gone from being
maverick weirdo outsiders to coming
almost inside the system and the power
balance with banks began to shift and
one of the great
scenes in your book is a point where you
have
bear stearns on the point of collapse
and effectively anna schwartz calls up
jim chanos one of the great short
sellers
and asks him to come to his age by going
on television
and essentially expressing confidence
in the bank which sort of encapsulates a
degree to which you know a little group
of gadflies had ended up in some ways
becoming not just integral to the system
but
sometimes having almost an equal power
footing yeah and i think that story
actually tells you something about the
way that the bubble formed and the way
that
wall street and the kind of media
apparatus around it works actually
because
you know you've got a lot of people
who are just congenitally bullish
in finance as you know
and so if you look at you know buy
recommendations to sell recommendations
that come out of wall street houses
there's always been you know 99 and a
half
buy recommendations for every sort of
semi-cell
and part of the skill that hedge funds
have had from early on is to ignore all
those buyer recommendations but call up
the brokerage you know as julian
robertson used to say to the to the
analysts you know i know you regard all
of these companies as your own children
but just tell me who is your least
favorite child
you know then you knew which one to sell
which one to be against and it's by
being willing to be negative that the
short sellers have got a niche not only
in investing but in terms of you know
information and what they're looking for
everybody else is looking for what's
going to go up these guys are focused on
what could blow up right uh and that
makes them an incredibly important
source of information i think generally
almost like the honest conscience of the
system will not be honest with the
conscience of the system perhaps right
right and i think journalists you know
would do well to talk more i mean they
already beginning to do it more but it
would be better to talk even more to
some of these hedge fund guys who are
willing to go short
uh they are talking about counters
haven't always been willing to talk or
you know you often when you talk to them
i mean as a journalist myself i know
when i talk to them i never quite know
where they're coming from right no
that's true but i think this particular
sub brand of hedge funds the short
sellers in fact jim cheney's is quite
open to the press
david einhorn who was one of the other
short sellers who came to the forum in
2008 is quite open to the press in fact
people say they might be too open to the
press because they're talking their book
they sell something and then they try
and get it down by spreading negative
stuff through the media now it seems to
me that actually if somebody has put
their own money where their mouth is and
sold something and made a bet
as a journalist i would be more inclined
to take their view seriously than if
it's some wall street analyst who hasn't
put money on it either way and is you
know just sort of sprouting an opinion
without betting on it
so i'm i don't have a problem with with
listening to people who are talking
their book
but that's not a view shared by all all
journalists
right well that certainly touches on the
much wider more controversial issue of
the you know the role of the media and
all this and the world the media and
covering um
covering the hedge fund industry but in
terms of
the way that hedge funds operate and the
theory that drives them one of the other
fascinating paradoxes in your book is
the fact that so much of the hedge fund
industry was driven by the theory of
efficient markets and free market ideals
and yet in practice what most of the
clever hedge fund players are doing is
actually exploiting market
inefficiencies i mean can you square
that up at all is it question of people
simply not believing their own theory
their own hype
well the people who believe the theory
of efficient markets were basically the
academics
and they believed it for rather a
limited amount of time i mean i've read
things as a result of the crisis that
say oh you know now academia has to
finally acknowledge that markets are not
efficient that's all nonsense i mean you
know i quote a paper published in 1990
by andre schleifer of harvard with larry
summers who now works of course in the
white house and they co-authored a paper
which said
the quote was something like um you know
if the efficient market hypothesis were
a stock it would have crashed in 1987
along with the wall street and
completely been wiped out in in 2008 i
think yeah that's right but even in 1990
the point is that academics acknowledged
that there were lots of kinks in the
efficient market theory i mean markets
may be efficient to first approximation
but beyond the first approximation
there's plenty of room to make money yes
and that's really the story of hedge
funds it's finding those
kinks and basically trading against
people i mean markets would be perfectly
efficient
if everybody in them was you know
incredibly focused on just getting the
price right but there are some
participants in markets
who are not focused on getting the price
right i mean the extreme example is a
central bank
which may be intervening to prop up a
currency because of a policy view about
where the exchange rate may be if you
trade against those people the central
banks they're simply you know they're
that sort of free money almost i mean
you know when george soros bet against
the bank of england in 1992 the bank of
england
you know was buying pounds not because
it thought pounds were worth something
but because john major the prime
minister was insisting that they would
stay inside the exchange rate mechanism
and in fact norman lamont the finance
minister at the time was trying to
persuade john major that he was crazy
they had to get out of the exchange rate
mechanism they couldn't make it stick
and john major for political reasons
sort of refused to listen for another
day so basically the hedge funds were
making a sort of political bet as much
that anything they're betting against
people who are not in the market who are
taking a view
without it being a view about the real
price of the security another example
would be you know when when you have um
you know a bankruptcy
and bonds in that company are suddenly
all downgraded there are lots of pension
funds which by the statutes of the
pension fund are not allowed to hold on
to the debt so if the debt loses its
value and goes down 30 cents on the
dollar it might be smart to hold it
because you think it will end up at 80
cents
but the pension fund isn't allowed to
have that view it has to sell
so in comes the pen the hedge fund which
is allowed to buy sell whatever it wants
whenever it wants just according to what
what's worth what and it's trading
against this pension fund which is
obliged to sell i mean you can't fail to
make money like that so it's not just
about using your brilliant mathematical
brain it's about sort of reading the
political climate or reading the
insanities or the inconsistencies in a
regulatory climate as well that's right
and i think in a way the subprime story
is a bit like that too there were lots
of players in the system
which were
you know playing in subprime buying
these securities either because they
you know had a regulatory reason that
they thought this was too attractive not
to do they thought you know because you
had to but no capital uh
against you could put a sort of
off-balance sheet and you know that was
very attractive because you know
mortgage related securities were treated
by the regulators in a way that treated
them as safe or they were triple a rated
and therefore there wasn't it so there
were a lot of reasons why uh banks and
other forms of institution over-invested
in these things and hedge funds because
they didn't have those kinds of
distortions to their decision-making
didn't make that mistake
for the most part what do you think the
hedgehogs have been doing so in relation
to sovereign debt over the last year do
you think again they're trying to
take advantage of some of the
um craziness of the political systems or
some of the arrangements
i mean certainly in the eurozone right
now there's a lot of finger pointing in
the case of say greece or spain towards
hedge funds yeah that's right i mean you
know on the one hand one can be sure
that in any big macro disturbance
hedge funds are there trying to make
money of course they are that's their
job at the same time i find it a bit of
ridiculous when you know the greeks say
oh our troubles are because hedge funds
have been attacking us come on i mean
you know you said you had a three
percent of gdp budget deficit then you
say oops we were lying to you and it's
now 13
and then it's the hedge funds fall that
you lied and that's you running a
totally unsustainable uh budget deficit
no i mean you know the primary cause of
the greek crisis is the greek government
and we should be clear about that but i
think you know hedge funds of course
they try to make money on the margin i
think it's we don't know yet quite
whether they've been able to i mean the
macro hedge funds have been reporting
results in the last few months they're
not looking actually all that great
suggesting to me that they haven't made
out like bandits in this european mess
yeah partly because it's a harder one to
trade you know in in in the 1992
european exchange rate crisis when italy
and then britain and then sweden got
whacked about in the currency markets in
each of those cases you could trade the
currency
of italy or britain or sweden now with
the euro
you can't because there's one currency
that's all linked together
so you can try to trade cds against the
debt
take a bet on a computer defaults work
credit default swaps derivatives um but
as you know i mean those
credit default swap markets they can be
a little bit of liquid you have a risk
that the government might come in and
suddenly declare that they're freezing
that market so it's harder to find a
strategy than say in the day the jaw saw
us where you simply went out and bought
a vast quantity of or bettered vastly
against these against sterling yes
exactly it's less liquid as hedge fund
people would say you can't express the
view so easily
right by express they mean make out like
bandits right well it gives a love
wonderful artistic gloss to what they're
actually doing in a sense
but in terms of looking to the future
i mean what do you think the future is
going to look like and what should it
look like i mean are you expecting the
hedge fund numbers to swell
do you think they'll get more assets
under management um or do you think
there could be a regulatory backlash
against them in the future
um
well i think there's a couple of things
i mean i think they will swell um you
know between 2000 and 2010
the assets probably tripled or something
in hedge funds i think in the next 10
years they could triple again so what
are they now just for
roughly um you know you see different
surveys with different numbers but more
or less two trillion dollars right or
just a bit under two trillion which
sounds like a lot of money to
non-bankers but of course that's still
pretty small compared to the assets of
the banking industry or the pension fund
exactly it's a drop in the ocean
compared to those people so you know i
think if you took pimco just one
uh you know bond
asset manager or blackrock you know put
those two together you'd have at least
two trillion in assets just in two
companies
so there's nine thousand and something
hedge funds all together they're as big
as two of these other ones so they got
plenty of room to grow right um
and i think if you look at the best
academic research on what value they
deliver to their customers they do
deliver real value i mean even if you
take out all the distortions that exist
in hedge fund reporting
and you really clean the data and the
point is there is value left over for
institutions that invest
even despite all these big fees so i
think so even after all this crazy
spending on planetariums and turkeys
exactly um so i think the institutions
are clever enough to see that so they're
going to put more money into hedge funds
and so the hedge funds will get bigger
and bigger and bigger but
to my mind there's a risk which is that
there'll be a few hedge funds
which sort of hoover up all this cash
because they are set up to appeal and
seduce
big institutions you know they have
wonderful reporting systems they send
you a nice glossy brochure twice a year
you know they've got so they almost look
like pimco yeah exactly i mean they
pimcoised themselves right um and of
course that tends to appeal to
governments too because they can go with
all the regulatory burden that they're
going to put exactly they've got armies
of lawyers they've got fantastic
computer systems that generate you know
all these reports and all the data that
a sort of high maintenance institutional
client would ask for
they just give it to you on a plate so
these kinds of platforms because you
know to create this platform very
expensive so there's a high barrier to
entry into that kind of
institutional hedge fund
and so i think once you've created that
platform you can just grow and grow and
grow then you start going public you
issue shares in yourself and some of
them have done that and then pretty soon
hey presto you know you're basically an
investment bank and then you actually
end up with a situation where they could
be systemically important exactly and
then they should be regulated
and i think you know hedge funds have
been wrongly accused of creating a risk
to the financial system in the past
but although that accusation has been
basically
99 wrong
so far it may be right in the future so
we need to be ready for that that's very
ironic i mean i have to ask you the key
question though because we're almost
finished but the key question which is
that if you're so fascinated by hedge
funds if you're now such an expert if
you think that they add so much to the
broader
economy
why aren't you running a hedge fund
yourself have you ever been tempted to
join one you know one thing i've learned
is that to make money as us as i said
before you know markets are basically
efficient to a first approximation so to
beat that you have to be so focused on
what you're doing all the time i mean
has to be an obsessive kind of thing you
have to be addicted to to watching your
investments
and i'm not going to develop that kind
of level of i mean i like writing i like
public policy i like telling stories i
like writing books i'd rather spend the
next three or four years you know on the
next book as opposed to you know
obsessing about basis points in the
markets and what's your next book going
to be bad no i don't know that yet
so if you wanted
regulators or governments or politicians
or non-bankers the kind of people who
say i just don't understand what hedge
funds do but i kind of think they're
probably evil great title et cetera if
you wanted them to take away one or two
key messages from this book what would
they be in terms of moving the
regulatory debate forward
no i'd say that we have to recognize
that there will be risk in financial
markets we have to ask who should manage
this risk and we have to recognize
that in the past when you've had a
financial crisis it's usually because
the incentives for financiers have been
distorted and encourage them to take too
much risk distorted by a government
backstop distorted by a so-called
trader's option that individuals within
a big bank may want to take more risk
because they'll get a big bonus
and the kind of financial vehicle that
we have that has fewer
of these distortive incentives are hedge
funds they have the managers have their
own money in the fund so they have an
incentive to avoid too much risk they
are not backstopped by the government so
they don't have that safety net they are
monitored very aggressively by their
creditors
so that means another safety check so
although they're not perfect and they do
fail sometimes they fail safely and it's
a better place for risk to be managed
than all the alternatives that i can
think of
it is of course a slightly hard sell
though because of you know i mean all
when ordinary people who are seeing
their incomes cut losing their jobs look
at these extraordinary characters you
know this fascinating story of how the
industry developed
looked all the money involved and
looked at all the freewheeling it's very
hard for them to not think well hang on
a second and why are they off in
um the cayman islands you know why are
they doing all this clever mathematical
stuff we don't understand i mean that's
right very easy targets and the answer
is more progressive taxation tax the
profits by all means but don't shut down
this form of investment management
because it's better and healthier for
financial for the financial system
and for the economy writ large and if
they were to tax the profits i mean how
much money do you think they could raise
build a few schools in the midwest or
well i mean a bit more healthcare i've
never been asked that question but i
mean if we just did back of the envelope
the top 25 um hedge fund managers on the
list of the you know the biggest earners
you know made about 25 billion dollars
between them
okay what just last when just in one
year yesterday in 2009 i think 2009
which was supposed to be a bad year for
most of the financial industries they
made 25
billion so if we just hiked their taxes
by 20 percentage points
right you make 5 billion right there i
mean 5 billion you know that's a few
schools
wow
well that's certainly a both inspiring
but also quite encouraging lesson to end
with so thank you very much indeed
sebastian for
providing a truly fascinating look at
the industry which is both very
interesting very juicy quite racy in
parts but actually raises some very core
fundamental policy questions and i for
one certainly hope that
regulators and politicians on both sides
of the atlantic listen to very seriously
so thank you nice director julian
monday